PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGNING.
>> Tucker: INTERESTING.
MARK STEYN, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: DEMOCRATS ARE UPSET
ABOUT SPEECHES LIKE THAT AND
ABOUT THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY
ITSELF OF COURSE.
BUT FOR MORE THAN A YEAR, THEY
HAVE CONSOLED THEMSELVES BY
LOOKING AHEAD TO THE MID-TERMS.
THE 2018 CONGRESSIONAL ELECTION.
THEY THOUGHT WE'RE GOING TO WIN
BIG.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE BACK POWER.
THEY MAY.
RECENT POLLS SHOW THAT DEMOCRATS
ONE MASSIVE LEAD IS SHRINKING.
NOW TO ALMOST NOTHING.
A NEW POLL OVER AT CNN SHOWS
THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE ONLY A
3-POINT ADVANTAGE ON A GENERIC
CONGRESSIONAL BALLOT.
IS THIS REAL?
WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
TOM BE VIN FOLLOWS THIS
CAREFULLY AND JOINS US TONIGHT.
WHAT IS THIS ABOUT, TOM?
IS IT REAL?
>> I THINK IT'S REAL, TUCKER.
YOU GO BACK AND LOOK IN MID
DECEMBER.
THE DEMOCRATIC LEAD IN MID
DECEMBER, WOULD YOU VOTE FOR
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT,
DEMOCRATS HAD A 13-POINT LEAD.
AS OF TODAY, IT'S DOWN TO 6.
IN OUR REAL CLEAR POLITICS
AVERAGE.
THE CNN POLL WENT 16 POINTS DOWN
TO THREE.
ANOTHER POLL SHOWING IT DOWN TO
ONE POINT.
SO THIS IS REAL.
IT IS JUST AS A POINT OF
REFERENCE, IN 2006, WHEN
DEMOCRATS WON 30 STATES, THEY
FINISHED WITH A 7.9 PERCENTAGE
LEAD.
SO I THINK THEY'RE IN THAT RANGE
WHERE IT'S MAKING THEM VERY
NERVOUS.
>> Tucker: SO REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS HAVE BEEN ASSUMING FOR
MONTHS -- I TALKED TO THEM --
THAT THEY WOULD LOSE BIG AND
NANCY PELOSI WOULD BE THE
SPEAKER.
NOW THEY HAVE A SHOT BUT THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT VOTER INTENSITY
ON THE LEFT IS STRONG.
HOW MEANINGFUL IS THAT
INTENSITY?
>> IT'S MEANINGFUL, PARTICULARLY
IN A MID-TERM ELECTION WHERE
IT'S ABOUT TURNING OUT THE BASE.
THE BECOMES HAVE HAD AN
ADVANTAGE THERE.
BUT BACK TO THE CNN POLL.
THAT WAS ANOTHER FINDING THAT
WAS DISTURBING FOR DEMOCRATS.
THEY SHOWED THE REPUBLICAN
INTENSITY IS UP NOW AND MATCHING
THE LEVEL OF THE DEMOCRATS.
IF THAT'S THE CASE, IT'S NOT AT
ALL A SURE BET THAT DEMOCRATS
WOULD TAKE BACK THE HOUSE IN
NOVEMBER.
>> Tucker: A LITTLE CONFUSING IN
TRUMP'S PERSONAL APPROVAL
NUMBERS ARE CONFUSING GIVEN THE
STORMY DANIELS STORY, WHICH IS
THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT STORY
EVER COVERED BY THE AMERICAN
NEWS MEDIA, HAS DOMINATED THE
COVERAGE FOR THE PAST THREE OR
FOUR WEEKS, MONTHS, I DON'T KNOW
HOW LONG IT'S BEEN.
THAT HASN'T HAD AN EFFECT.
>> NO.
IN FACT, IT'S THE OPPOSITE,
TUCKER.
IN MID DECEMBER WAS TRUMP'S LOW
POINT IN THE REAL CLEAR POLITICS
RATING.
HIS AVERAGE WAS 37.
HE'S AT 43.4.
HE'S GAINED 6 1/2 POINTS OVER
THE COURSE OF THAT PERIOD.
AS YOU MENTIONED, THE ENTIRE
TIME, IT'S THE STORMY DANIELS
ONSLAUGHT.
NOT ONLY HAS IT HURT HIS
NUMBERS, HIS NUMBERS HAVE BEEN
TICKING UPWARDS THE ENTIRE TIME.
AGAIN, THAT'S SOMETHING THAT --
YOU SEE DEMOCRATS.
YOU TALK TO THEM.
THEY'RE ANNOYED BY THIS.
TALK TO NANCY PELOSI AND OTHERS,
THEY SAY IT'S DISTRACTING FROM
OUR MESSAGE.
THEY WANT TO REACH VOTERS.
VOTERS HAVE TUNED THAT OUT AND
PAYING ATTENTION TO THE OTHER
STUFF WHICH TRUMP HAS HAD A GOOD
FEW WEEKS.
>> Tucker: AMAZING.
THEIR MESSAGE.
WE DON'T HAVE TIME FOR YOU TO
TELL ME WHAT THAT IS.
I APPRECIATE IT, TOM.
THANK YOU.
>> YOU BET.
>> Tucker: YOU JUST HEARD THE
NUMBERS ON THE UPCOMING ELECTION
ARE INTERESTING.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE STILL AHEAD
BUT NOT NEARLY AS POPULAR ACTION
THEY WERE SIX MONTHS AGO.
IT'S WEIRD THE PRESIDENT IS
UNLIKED BY HALF THE COUNTRY.
DEMOCRATS OUGHT TO BE WAY AHEAD.
AS YOU JUST HEARD, THEY'RE NOT.
WHY IS THAT?
COULD IT BE THAT FOR ALL THE
PROBLEMS THAT THE REPUBLICANS
HAVE, AND THEY'RE REAL,
DEMOCRATS ARE PERCEIVED AS LESS
APPEALING?
LOOKS THAT WAY.
THE QUESTION IS WHY.
WE HAVE THEORIES.
WE CAN SHOW YOU A MILLION
EXAMPLES.
HERE'S ONE FROM YESTERDAY THAT
CAME TO MIND.
WATCH AS THIS MSNBC PANEL, WHICH
IS CLOSE TO A DEMOCRATIC PARTY
FOCUS GROUP YOU'LL FIND, GUSHES
OVER THE PORN LAWYER WHOSE EYES
ARE TOO CLOSE TOGETHER.
WATCH THIS.
>> MICHAEL AVANETTI IS A BEAST.
>> HE'S A BEAST.
HE KEEPS POPPING DONALD TRUMP
AND ALL OF HIS FOLKS IN THE
MOUTH.
JOHN MEACHEM SAYS HE MAY BE THE
SAVIOR OF THE REPUBLIC.
>> HE KILLED THE NEWS OF THE
IRAN DEAL IN ONE BIG STROKE.
HE IS A MASTER OF THE MEDIA
CYCLE.
>> I OWE MICHAEL AVANETTI AN
APOLOGY.
I SAID I'VE SEEN YOU EVERYWHERE.
I WAS WRONG, BROTHER.
YOU HAVE A LOT TO SAY.
THE DEMOCRATS COULD LEARN
SOMETHING FROM YOU.
YOU'RE MESSING WITH TRUMP A LOT
MORE THAN THEY ARE.
>> Tucker: HERE'S A POLITICAL
RULE OF THEM.
IN THE CREEPY PORN LAWYER IS THE
SAVIOR OF THE REPUBLIC IN YOUR
VIEW, YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT TRYING
VERY HARD TO MIDDLE AMERICA.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT.
IN THE LAST 1 1/2 YEARS, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS DOUBLED
DOWN ON EVER REBEHAVIOR THAT GOT
TRUMP ELECTED IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THEY PREFER ILLEGALS TO U.S.
CITIZENS.
THEY'RE OPEN ABOUT IT.
IN SCHOOLS AND SPORTS, THE
MILITARY, THEY DENOUNCE THE IDEA
OF BIOLOGICAL DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN MEN AND WOMEN.
THAT SOMETHING THAT EVERY
CULTURE FROM ANCIENT EGYPT
UNDERSTAND.
TWO NIGHTS AGO, "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" CRITICIZED MIKE POMPEO
AND HIS TRIP TO NORTH KOREA.
THEY RAN THE HEADLINE, AT A KEY
MOMENT, TRUMP'S TOP DIPLOMAT IS
A THOUSAND MILES AWAY LIKE IT'S
A SIN.
THE PURPOSE OF THE VISIT IS TO
SECURITY THE RELEASE OF THREE
AMERICAN PRISONERS.
THE TIMES IS NOT IMPRESSED BY
THAT.
MIKE POMPEO WORKS FOR TRUMP SO
IT MUST BE BAD.
WHAT EVER ELSE HE'S DONE, TRUMP
HAS DRIVEN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
OFF THE DEEP END AND IT'S
SHOWING IN THE POLLS.
AND CHRISTY, YOU'VE BEEN AROUND
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY A LONG
TIME.
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
YOU'VE HEARD TOM BEVINS SAYING
THEIR MESSAGE IS NOT GETTING
AUTOMATIC.
TRUTH IS IT'S BAD.
IT'S MORE OF AN ANIMAL REACTION.
>> WHATEVER THE MESSAGE IS, IT'S
WORKING.
LOOK AT THE CONGRESSIONAL AND
STATE ELECTIONS SINCE NOVEMBER
2016.
DEMOCRATS HAVE FLIPPED 40 PLUS
SEATS AT THE STATE LEGISLATIVE.
OFTEN IN DISTRICTS WHERE TRUMP
WON BY 20 OR 30 POINTS.
SO WE CAN QUIBBLE AND THE
MESSAGE BUT WE CAN'T QUIBBLE
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S WORKING.
IT CLEARLY SEEMS TO BE.
>> Tucker: TO SOME EXTENT, TRUMP
IS LOATHED BY HALF THE
POPULATION.
IT'S HIS FIRST MID-TERM.
HISTORICALLY THEY'RE GOING TO
GET SEATS.
THE QUESTION IS WHERE IS THE
WAVE.
ONE OF THE MESSAGES IS, THERE'S
NO DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
SEXES.
BIOLOGICAL REALITY IS LIKE FAKE.
>> NOBODY IS SAYING THAT.
>> Tucker: WE NEED TO REORGANIZE
SOCIETY.
IT'S MORE RADICAL THAN ANYTHING
TRUMP HAS SAID.
>> SUGGEST YOU TO POINT ME TO
THE CANDIDATE IS SAYING THAT.
DEMOCRATS ARE BEING
REASONABLE --
>> Tucker: WOULD IT BE POSSIBLE
FOR A DEMOCRAT RUNNING FOR
OFFICE IN THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY
TO SAY THERE'S TWO BIOLOGICAL
SEXES, MALE AND FEMALE?
THAT'S IT.
IF YOU SAID THAT --
>> I WOULD SUGGEST THEY TALK
ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
ARE YOU JOKING?
THEY'RE THE ONES PUSHING THE
CHANGES ON THE REST OF US,
INCLUDING BATHROOM THING.
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I'M SERIOUS.
>> IT'S REPUBLICANS DOING THE
BATHROOM THING.
NORTH CAROLINA, THAT WAS A
ENTIRELY --
>> Tucker: NOBODY IMAGINED THERE
WERE MORE THAN TWO SEXES UNTIL
20 MINUTES AGO.
IT WAS DEMOCRATS.
IT'S A BIG CHANGE.
MAYBE BIOLOGY ISN'TS REAL.
IT'S NOT A MAINSTREAM POSITION.
THEY SPEND A LOT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT IT.
DOES IT HELP?
>> IF YOU WANT TO MAKE THE
ARGUMENTS THIS DEMOCRATS SHOULD
OR SHOULDN'T BE TALKING ANT
IMPEACHMENT, STORMY DANIELS AND
HER LAWYER.
WE CAN HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO.
THERE'S NO MAINSTREAM
CANDIDATE --
>> Tucker: REALLY?
YOU CAN SAY AS A DEMOCRAT --
SERIOUS.
I THINK IT'S RE-ORDERING SOCIETY
IS A BIG DEAL.
AND PRETENDING BIOLOGY IS FAKE,
TOO.
YOU COULD HAVE A DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE SAYING THERE'S TWO
BIOLOGICAL SEXES AND HE COULD
GET AWAY WITH THAT?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN IS WHAT I'M SAYING.
I THINK AGAIN, IF YOU LOOK BACK
TO THE WAYS THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN PERFORMING UP TO THIS
POINTS, WHATEVER IT IS THAT
THEY'RE DOING IS WORKING.
THERE'S FAR NOR ENERGY, THERE'S
MORE SMALL DOLLAR DONATIONS AND
THAT LEADS TO MORE VOLUNTEERS
AND LEADS TO A BETTER SLATE OF
CANDIDATES IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
>> Tucker: A LOT OF IT IS TRUE.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
PROBABLY MORE ENERGY AND ALL